(audience applauding and cheering)
- [Howie] You know Terry.
- [Jackie] Oh hi, how are you?
- [Terry] I'm good, how are you?
- This is so weird.
I gotta tell you why this is weird,
because the reason she's here today.
You know that, Terry, you're
an amazing family man.
She is such a huge fan of Kelly Clarkson.
Kelly Clarkson is her jam.
Your, right?
- Yeah.
- And you always wanted
to meet Kelly, right?
- Yeah, that's my dream.
- [Howie] That is her dream.
(Terry laughs)
In fact, the first time I did this show,
I did it on Zoom
and she was so disappointed
because I did it on Zoom.
I don't know if we have
a picture of me on Zoom.
So look behind me,
I don't know if you can
see, the plant behind me?
Jackie is standing behind the plant.
- [Terry] Oh, she's been there!
- [Howie] Yes, that's Jackie.
- [Terry] She's been there! (laughing)
- [Howie] That's Jackie behind the plant
just so that she can see Kelly.
(audience and Terry clapping)
That's you, right?
- Yeah.
- And then, you have two
kids, so you were busy.
- [Jackie] Yeah.
- And I came and did it live,
and I didn't tell you,
and were you mad at me?
- Yeah, I cried.
- [Howie] Yeah, she did.
She cried.
- I cried.
I was here and I didn't tell her,
and you didn't get to meet Kelly.
- And then I saw your schedule.
- [Howie] Yeah.
- And saw you were coming to be on Kelly.
- So I cleared my schedule
- [Howie] Yeah.
- and got a sitter for my kids
so that I could meet Kelly.
- [Howie] Yeah.
- And then it's you.
(laughing)
- And as a parent, if you
can't disappoint your children,
(laughing)
what is it worth it?
- I love you.
- I love you too.
- But I'm not, I'm not that stoked.
- Terry's here.
- Hey.
- I love you too. I love you too.
- Yes.
- You know, I was, you know
I was Kelly Clarkson's
first guest on her pilot.
- Really?
- [Terry] I, I'm telling you that.
Little known, and I was so happy.
I was like, this show is gonna be big,
and look what it became.
Look what it, and I understand
why you love Kelly so much.
- I do.
- [Howie] She loves Kelly.
She hosts the podcast with me.
But don't be that disappointed.
Just like Terry, my
jam, my favorite thing,
and I think you are enjoying it too,
doing a podcast with me?
- Yeah, it's fun.
- I, I love just working with my kids.
You work with your kid,
you work with your son.
- Exactly. I love doing your podcast too.
- [Howie] Yeah.
- That was a lot of fun with you.
- [Howie] Check it out. howiemandel.com.
- It was great.
- Yes.
- Good Stuff.
- What? Oh, the merch.
I brought merch for the audience.
- [Terry] Yeah.
(crowd cheering)
Woo!
(Jackie laughing)
- [Howie] I, I only brought one, so share.
- Yeah.
- Anyway, (laughing)
I feel like I disappointed you today
that I'm here and you
didn't get to meet Kelly.
And I want to do
something special for you.
- Okay.
- [Howie] I do.
- Is she here?
- [Howie] What?
- [Jackie] Is she here?
- Well, can we do something
special to make it
to make this a little bit
easier for my daughter?
Is there something we could.
- Oh.
- [Terry] Yeah!
(laughing)
- See?
- Oh yeah!
- No because nobody's gonna know.
Here, here.
- All right.
- This is what I'm, this is what I'll do.
This is what we should do.
Here, well, let's get a shot.
Terry, stand up.
- Yeah, I'll get it.
- So this is it.
Stand there, there, and stand there.
- Come on, get all of us!
- This will be a nice shot.
This, oh, we need somebody there.
We need, there's somebody.
I don't have, have a,
I don't bring my phone or camera.
Does somebody in the audience have a.
- We can just pretend there's a camera.
- Well, no, don't. But then no.
Somebody in the audience?
Do you have a, do you have a camera?
Come here. You want to
take a picture of us?
- [Audience Member] I would love to.
- Yeah, let me, is there a microphone?
Gimme a microphone.
What's your, what's your name?
- [Audience Member] I'm Kay Montgomery.
- Hi. Hi, Cam, Howie.
This is my daughter Jackie, and Terry.
And, and a fake. All right.
Will you, would you get a picture of us?
- [Audience Member]
Yes, I will. Absolutely.
- Okay. Alright. Just all right.
Okay. No, horizontal.
Horizontal, yeah.
- Okay, yes, sir.
- Yeah. And just back, back a little bit.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah, okay?
And can you, it'd be good if you like
'cause you shoot from up,
- Dad.
- because the lights are coming down.
- Oh, so kneel a little?
- Yeah. kneel, a little.
Kneel down, down, down, down, down.
Yes. Okay.
And take a picture of us.
- Yeah!
- All right, alright.
We'll be back with more
show right after this.